la martinique sous haute surveillance la
phase 1 du programme d' alerte des
épidémies de dengue a été déclenchée par
la rs l' agence régionale de santé
en effet un cas de dengue a été
diagnostiqué dans notre île un cas isolé
selon les autorités mais qui est observé
à la loupe
on est très très vigilant c'est à dire
que on a d'abord mis en place des
circuits pour les prélèvements
biologiques pour pouvoir pour ne pas
rater les quarts ça c'est une chose
on a informé tous les médecins les
médecins sentinelles mais les autres
médecins également on a mis autour du
autour du cas que l'on a eues on a fait
des actions de lutte anti-vectorielle
pour éviter que ce cas là donne
naissance à un foyer etc etc et on va
relancer la communication déjà cinq ans
que la martinique n'a pas connu
d'épidémie de dengue
même si les derniers cas recensés
remonte à 2016
la maladie n'a pas disparu on est dans
une zone d'endémie et il est évident que
les épidémies de dengue reviennent
périodiquement
là on a eu un petit peu de une accalmie
relativement longue par rapport à la
dengue
même si je répète qu on a eu quand même
chikungunya et vicat qui ont été des
épidémies très très dur mais on était
dans une phase d'accalmie de la dengue
pour éviter que l'unique cas de dengue
ne se transforme en l'épidémie il faut
respecter un certain nombre de règles
dont la plus importante consiste à se
débarrasser des eaux stagnantes